>> Hi. I'm Asha Thomas.
I represent Advaith Foundation.
We are an NGO in
the space of education,
especially K-12, focused on K-12.
We started out looking at
the underserved children.
We said we'll give them
access to schooling,
and we'll take care of
their after school,
because for them to be
successful in school,
they need a lot of
support out of school.
So, we started as a residential
program and subsequently,
based on our experiences there,
we moved on to starting
our own school.
Here, as a school,
the model is an integrated model.
We have children from all
different socioeconomic status.
Apart from these children who
stay with us in our hostel,
we have children from
the neighborhood,
again, from a similar background
who come to the school.
We also have a portion
of the children who come in,
our fee-paying children.
The model was designed in
such a way so that we can ensure
there is certain amount of
quality that will be maintained.
We believe that if you have
a little bit of
the market facing,
they will bring in those forces
to ensure the quality
is retained,
and also, it is
a sustainable model.
So, today, I'm here to speak
about The Samhita Academy.
That is the name of our school.
We have other projects
which we've started,
which is like a Platform
for School Leadership
last year and Skilling
Institute this year.
These are still in
the very early stages.
So, just to give
a little background
of the children who are coming
from the disadvantaged
background,
this is probably something
you're not familiar with.
They have lot of what we call the
hidden baggage that they
come to school with.
So, apart from the academic
struggles that they have,
this is something
that they deal with,
and this is the kind
of diversity,
and this is the outcomes that we
can see in the classrooms.
The blue is the
privileged classes,
coming with English
exposure, all of that.
Then, the next lot of children
are the children where we
support them in
our own hostel facility.
The third group, which they've
reached grade four now,
they are the children
who don't get
any kind of support
outside of school hours.
Most of our effort
goes in bringing up
this huge amount of effort trying
to bring them to grade level.
So, we have a lot of, of course,
issues that we could think of,
but we narrowed down
to two areas here.
One was in the whole area
of assessments.
So, today, it's
a very manual process.
The children hand-write it,
teachers correct it by
hand, question by question.
Then, there's one total marks
which is given, and then,
that gets entered into
some systems for
reporting, all of that.
But that doesn't really
help me with anything.
It doesn't help me to remediate.
It just tells me how
the whole class is doing.
There are so many children
at this grade,
this grade, but by topic level,
by the strategies that
we may have used,
I have no data to tell me what
worked, what didn't work.
Then, the teachers
spend a lot of time
just doing all this manual work,
which they could have spent
probably in remediation,
where we find very little time
actually for them to do.
So, these are some
of the problems.
We have totaling
errors, analysis.
Again, here, I'm not just
talking about quantitative,
how many got it right, wrong,
but also maybe looking at
some of the open-ended questions,
that kind of data,
and some qualitative input
on the answers that
are coming out,
and whether there's understanding
based on the taxonomy
of the question,
whether it is a higher [inaudible]
question, is it rote learning.
So, those data, it's all lost.
There's nothing there
for us to work on.
So, that was one of the areas
that we had identified.
We don't really have too
much of data right now.
It's like I said, at
the whole paper level,
I have some marks.
This is what the paper
would look like.
Some of them are like worksheets,
some are foolscap sheets
into which they're writing.
So, this is where the data is.
I think, Saurav, you had
suggested some technology.
>> So, when we work
with them, we realize
it's a very paper intensive job.
So, today, in
the corporate world,
we have intelligent
scanners which scan
not only [inaudible] data but
also OCRs have been able
to match handwriting and
patterns, and things like that.
So, if a scanner with
an intelligent AI algorithm
can be put in place which
scans the answer sheet and
gives some bit of analysis
almost in a real-time basis for
the teacher to
undertake so that she
can then appropriately
take remedial action.
Today, what is happening is,
there is a teacher bias.
There is fatigue in
teachers, let's be honest,
because each teacher
actually translates to,
what, 30 or 40 children?
>> Thirty, but she does
at least 90 children,
covers 90 children.
>> Ninety children. Even
in the corporate world,
if you do a span of control,
we say that's not
a very optimized model.
So, thinking about
technology implementation,
more from an intelligence
perspective,
scanners are available, yes,
but maybe an intelligent
algorithm which
captures this information
in a digital format,
provides real-time analytics,
would be of great help.
So, you want to add,
Asha, more on this?
>> Yeah. So, thing is,
this is one of the areas.
So, what is the kind of
qualitative analysis
it can give me?
I don't know because that would
depend on what is the state
of the technology.
>> So, you have
the GI or GMAT exam.
So, it's MCQ, math,
and quan, and there's
an essay section.
So, the essay section, there's
a human grader and
a computer grader.
So, essentially,
the computer grader also follows
similar AI algorithms we had
for each prompt
what we are given.
Let's say you're talking
about road traffic accidents.
Your answer should
have certain keywords
on which you'll be graded.
So, similarly, when you ask
questions on your subjects,
maybe science, geography,
history, whatever,
that particular answer would
have certain keywords or
certain facts which
a good answer must have.
So, probably that can be
fed into the algorithm,
and on those basis,
a good grade can be given.
If there's a discrepancy,
a human teacher can
rectify or add to it.
So, that could be a method
which you could adopt.
>> Right, Richa.
You had a question.
>> [inaudible]. Actually, when
I was visiting MIT last time,
some of the people there told me
how they [inaudible]
really large courses
with several hundred students.
I think there's technology
available, for example,
in the US to scan a bunch
of answers [inaudible] ,
automatically split them
in different questions.
So, each teaching
assistant specializes
in grading a few questions.
So, even if that
grading is manual,
the intelligence doesn't have
to be just in evaluation.
The intelligence can also
be in routing and matching
the answers to the right person
[inaudible] who's human skill
more efficiently.
>> [inaudible]. Just
go into the next area,
which is likely more specialized,
which is from our special
education department. Yes.
>> Also, I've a question about
the paradigm of
scanning [inaudible].
So, you need to do it one at
a time or you just [inaudible] ,
because lots of AI involved
[inaudible] batch build
unsupervised models.
For example, models of what
character sequences
will occur [inaudible].
That could be very well used
to improve the accuracy of
batch [inaudible] than
scan one at a time.
>> That's agreed
upon. So, today you
see they're in a manual stage.
So, whatever technology
solutions that we get out
of this session and
this two days of workshop,
and we do a technical
feasibility and
a financial viability
for the NGO to adopt.
They would be more
than happy to get it.
They're here to seek
help more to move from
that manual to intelligent
digital journey. Yeah.
>> We are actually
[inaudible] in one area.
So we are building
something similar but we
come from a different model.
So we are integrating,
so we came from a smartphone,
doing exams on smartphone models,
but I don't think that works.
But as part of this,
since we had the
entire infrastructure
built around evaluation.
We are also building
the scanning mode into it.
Which is basically,
you just a bunch,
there are scanners which
you can bulk feed it kind
of pulls it from
that and segregates into
the questions and stuff.
What we also are working
together with this is
also a question back
that goes hand-in-hand
with it there where you
talk about Bloom stack and so
on, whatever it is you want to.
So you can actually
set questions based
on some learning models,
and than you evaluate it.
Since I'm a teacher myself,
this thing about
albeit taking AI,
taking the role of a teachers,
I'm still not comfortable,
because you just kill creativity.
Someone doesn't answer
the way whatever.
I mean, I don't
like that anymore,
but nonetheless, certain
other aspects can be done.
We are doing some work, I'll
talk to you after that.
>> That's great idea.
That's a good dialog
and a good discussion to have.
So let's just move, keep
moving on the next.
>> Yes. The next areas in
our earlier reading program
and I'll get to you.
>> One of our
important observation,
learning has been and
that the head-start that
we can give our kids
is learning to read.
Because most of them
enter grade one,
don't have skills in terms of
literacy competency let alone
reading in English
and when they start,
when they need to access
content in English,
then it becomes like
a double barrier for them.
So all our grade one
and grade two kids
go through something
called a reading program.
Now for that, we have to spend
a lot of time doing like,
whole-class screening
to understand
who our kids who are at risk,
who are kids who
are at high risk,
who are kids who are
already proficient,
and how can we accelerate
the kids who are
already proficient.
Then once we do get them into
groups where we do
systematic intervention,
it is the progress monitoring,
we do know we've followed
three things in
our reading program.
Read to Self, Read to Someone,
Listen to Reading and
then the teachers are
one who is kind of a facilitator,
who kind of makes
the whole reading process,
she just demonstrates
the whole thing.
So when we do know
that time spent on
reading by yourself is so
important and that leads to
a high amount of success,
we are unable to monitor
that independent reading program.
We're talking about
six years old and
seven-year-old who do not
have much self-regulation, right?
So a lot of things get losses
to how are they reading
during that independent time.
A teacher will maximum have,
say about 15 minutes a week,
to listen to one child
read, right?
But the rest of the time they're
reading to someone or
reading to a peer,
and those are
very vital opportunities
that give us a lot of
deep skill building
that happens in
children and that
is also something
that we are looking at
how do we capture it,
so that if there is a way,
I mean today we do have
a simple reading recorder,
but then the teacher has
to go through the process
of listening to
all these recordings,
then analyze it,
do the data entry,
whether errors are happening,
what is the next stage.
So what we'll also looking at is
a technology solution
that will minimize that,
which'll capture
the student reading,
interpret it for the teacher so
that most of the time then is
spent on actually teaching
and then planning for teaching.
So that is what we
are looking at, yes.
>> So, I'm assuming you're
talking about reading aloud.
>> Yes. See grade one
to grader two kids,
most of them anyway
are reading aloud.
There has been a
lot of work, sorry.
Yeah. So there has
been a lot of work
done on reading tutors and like,
almost eight to nine
years ago there was
something called
Project LISTEN from CMU,
which was a speech
recognition based system.
I had done a study at
that time ages and ages ago,
eight-nine years ago with some of
the schools around
Bangalore where we had
integrated some of
the Pratham books into that
and we did it at
primary school level.
We had, I think
grade three and grade four,
and in government
schools grade nine.
It had all the books
classified grade-wise
from K1 to K12.
It had, not K12, K10
probably, nine-10.
It had exercises,
it would give students
feedback and what it
would do is actually cull
all that information and prepare
reports for the teachers
at the end of the thing.
So there is, what I'm
not sure is whether
Project LISTEN is actually
opensource and it's
available for everybody or not,
but I can put you in touch
with the PROPHET CMU who
does this and you could have
a conversation with them.
Because whatever you're asking
for is actually available.
Like, yeah.
>> Thank you. We will
certainly take it.
>> A little bit more sophisticated
because it does a lot
of analysis on
the student's reading
and prepares reports and
lets the teacher have
the data so that
they can actually
monitor it and see what's
happening and workings working.
>> See, these parameters
we have developed over
the years in terms of looking
at learning patterns of
especially high-risk and
struggling readers, right?
So we do have the
parameters. We do.
It is the time
taken that we're looking at
how do we enable teachers,
so that their focus is more that
quality time that they
spend with the kids is
based on taking them to
the next goal rather
than spending a lot of time
back and doing error analysis.
So that is we are
increasingly are
challenge with a number
of kids is on.
But I'll certainly
connect with you.
>> Yeah, I'll tell you more
about how that works
because parameters,
there's one thing that
the teacher might have,
some kind of parameters in
their mind and that goes
back to what she was
saying that actually having
AI replace teachers is probably
controversial right now,
but there are parameters that
would be useful for you.
So the parameters that they use
to evaluate are also
bad pedagogy-based.
It's not like just
randomly created.
>> I know I understand
that. I understand that.
>> Yeah. So we can take
the dialog further
up in the breakout session,
I think in the interest of time
let's just make sure that.
>> Yeah, so I think these
are the tools that we identified.
Of course, there was a lot of
exciting things on
that NLP and all that,
maybe that I can do at the table.
>> Absolutely.
>> And find out a little bit
more on those which could
help our English
language learners.
Those who have
absolutely no exposure
to English so that's
another area,
but I think we'll take it
to the break of session.
>> Next slide. So, this is
a kind of datasets
that are currently
available with the team out here.
So any opportunity to
optimize this and make
it more effective and efficient
would be much more
of appreciable.
That's the whole idea,
to bring this to the table.